My understanding of the main difference
between a unicorn investor and
sort of a long tail investor is
a unicorn investor is looking for
other investors to pile on.
That's where they make their money.
So, a first investor in a unicorn
company will say, hey, you know what,
I think this could be sold
as a billion dollar company.
I'm going to put in enough money to
make the valuation a billion dollars.
That sets off a press cycle.
That press cycle is a feeding frenzy for
other investors who
want to also pile on.
And as those other investors pile on,
the first investor is actually reaping
the benefits of these
other additional pile ons.
But that whole business model of
investors feeding on investors
is dependent on no drop in valuation,
which requires continued growth with
the company that's been invested in,
either in the technology space,
the people space, the market space,
some metric that they consider
important has to keep getting bigger or
more valuable, even though it's only
perceived value, the whole business can
fall apart if the true value of
the company is never realized.
This is where tech bubbles
come from actually.
Now in the long tail investor side of
things, those investors are actually
interested in legitimately
helping Bootstrap companies and
make them successful and
sustainable because they see the
sustained long term value of investing
in a spread of different businesses
that will be around in 20 or 50 years.
It's that continued growth but
slowly without that get rich
quick kind of mentality.
Those are the investors actually I
prefer because it actually benefits
society and is a good place for
you to put your business trust.